House Majority Leader Kevin McCarthy
congressman it's always great to see you
thank you for being here I want to get
started with the letter that you sent
the Speaker Nancy Pelosi to try to get
her to push back on this proxy voting as
well as to ensure that certain key
committees come back to work tell us
about the letter you sent her and the
response you've gotten but well I said
the letter to her last week she wanted
to change 200 years of history so
constituents lend their voice to their
congresswoman or congressman for two
years and want to hold them accountable
what Nancy Pelosi want to do was
Congress was to be able to hold 200
proxies 200 different votes for members
of Congress to make her more powerful
and control the floor
fortunately after my letter in our
discussion with her she has pulled back
on that but Congress is essential we
have worked through the Civil War World
War two and others we need to get to
work and just as States wouldn't open up
completely at once we need committees to
come back in like Armed Services to do
the national defense bill you have
appropriators making sure government is
funded you could bring oversight back to
look at the whu-oh and this current
administration of the w-h-o is acting
not like the World Health Organization
but more like the Wuhan Health
Organization we should actually get the
facts and the answers and those
committees could come back with not the
entire Congress to show that we are
working for the American public
just as we watch these states phase in
in a safe healthy manner but that's not
what she wants right she wants everyone
to not come back until May and is that
right and is that the plan that that is
the current plan but after my
conversation with the speaker she put
together three Republicans and three
Democrats myself and the majority leader
and others to start working on planning
on how we can do this I don't think you
should change the history of how
Congress votes to empower one side
Congress can work we just proved it we
have passed some of the biggest bills in
the history of Congress during this
pandemic we can open up in a manner and
have committees working they can work in
bigger buildings so they have social
distancing they can do it in a safe
manner why all the members aren't there
and we can have product being worked
for the American public what why is the
speaker now talking about November
elections must go on she says that the
president may try to postpone it how can
we ensure a safe election and let's talk
a bit about China that has certainly
been the dominant story but a number of
your colleagues completely missed China
as a threat as they continue to
investigate Russia and the ghosts of
collusion for years
yeah let's first talk about this is at
the beginning of Nancy Pelosi the
speaker talking about November's
elections she brought this up and held
up the first cares act the act of a more
than two trillion dollars this is when
she wanted to institute change election
law go for the green New Deal pay for
Planned Parenthood for every moment
these Democrats have tried to held held
up each bill to play politics with it
and I don't expect her continue the same
but we will move forward with the
November election and not try to give
advantage to one party or the other but
make sure they're fair you are correct
yeah Maria you were one of the first
that was showing what China was doing I
remember Twitter people on Twitter
criticizing you because you were the one
of the first ones coming out they're
concerned about the laboratories and we
want concerned about was China being
honest with the with the American public
now we see a hoenn study by Southampton
that had China been honest with the
world 95 percent of this never would
have happened what China has done has
directly led to American deaths and this
is where we should have started long ago
and President Trump has been correct
about China long before when he was just
a candidate about our supply chain it
comes to our pharmaceuticals critical
minerals and others and one thing we
should learn from this pandemic is never
put ourselves in this position again
look what Japan is doing Japan is
pulling back those companies from China
we should do the same our allies could
as well and we could make the world
stronger and never be in this situation
again yeah do you make a great point
thank you for that the president
completely changed the conversation on
China will there be a fourth stimulus
package congressman what are you looking
for in terms of put
in another release bill even as even
McConnell your colleague on the Senate
is questioning the debt now the debt
that this country faces is higher than
the actual size of the economy 22
trillion dollars that is a real fear
every Great Society has collapsed when
they've overextended themselves we've
just passed four bills more than two
point seven trillion dollars and you
combine this with what the Fed is doing
that's seven trillion dollars into the
economy let's first look results before
we want to go back and try to rework
another bill I listen to the Democrats
but this is where their socialism comes
out they pick the dollar amount before
they even know what it needs to be done
let's get this implemented into society
let's let the seven trillion dollars
work let's look at results before we
react to anything else moving forward
okay we'll leave it there congressman
it's great to see you this morning thank
you so much sir Thank You Maria